[Musique]
le deuil
contribution
grammy ladsous
le à mon titre
[Musique]
acceptable
ici pas toujours
les 9 mes filles
[Musique]
et c'est ici qu'il faut construire
et l'ader et la largeur
ceux que je ne nie pas
voir le gant moqueur
devant
un esclave de la paix
une loi procédurale
avec ça
stylo de football
à la nuisance nietzsche
un mini lecteur
bien bien
[Musique]
jouer avec le soudan et juillet
Oh
est de l'eau
sûrement un club
et maintenant que je suis maman
votre blog
[Musique]
col de l'homme d'or
s'ils ne sont pas supprimés
[Musique]
que portez-vous belle
Alors
[Musique]
zaplana votre équipe
j'ai abandonné
le gris
sacs
votre pays final est élargi
laps
[Musique]
avec l'un de moi
Salut
[Musique]
un rapport
nous la passons
à moi
[Musique]